recreating the fog of war or at least
attempting to
these are everyday civilian ukrainians
who have volunteered to fight against
russia's occupation of their country
spending the next few weeks at this
military base in england to learn the
basics of how to become soldiers
i want my children grandchildren
will live in free
independent and flourishing country
this recruit who goes by the nickname
zakar says his motivations are deeply
personal as well as patriotic
my friend was killed in odessa
that's why it's also my aim
to revenge for him
because
we know that a lot of
common unguilty people are dying under
the bombardment the aim at least
initially is to give 10 000 ukrainians
basic military training over the coming
months i mean it's been humbling
absolutely
they are really motivated all of them
i've not seen one yet who's put his hand
up and went no i don't want to do this
the their will to win is fantastic
within weeks canadian forces will join
the british as trainers here part of an
international alliance of this uk-led
training program up to 225 soldiers from
canada for a four-month commitment most
from the third battalion of princess
patricia's canadian light infantry in
edmonton some are already here and
getting ready to start it's a pretty
profound thing when you think about it
so what it means for us is it's really
important to deliver hard realistic
training for the short time we have them
and
and i guess prepare them for what lies
ahead this will be a resumption of
canada's operation unifier training
mission but now with much higher stakes
it was paused when russia invaded
ukraine in february over the previous
seven years canadian forces had
instructed 33 000 ukrainian soldiers and
security personnel canadian special
forces are also on the ground in ukraine
conducting training exercises there too
redmond shannon global news in the south
east of england